what's up kids this episode of firing
the kid with mark the body harley
is coming soon a few housekeeping notes
for you
thick boy just dropped new merch this
morning thinkboy.com that's three
c's t-h-i-c-c-cc boy.com we got the new
sleeves hoodies you've seen us rocking
in the thick boy
vlogs we got uh shorts for the summer
it's all there at thickboy.com
also next week uh tuesday pre-sale
tickets for
my big san antonio shows nervous about
this one but i think we pulled off kids
this is san antonio the bud light
theater
the att bud light garden center it's
happening
and that's september 24th and 25th
pre-sale tickets go on sale tuesday
promo code thick to get your tickets
early
uh other than that la and first spots in
la will happen july 16th through the
17th at the haha
shaub and friends july 16th to 17th at
the haha
we just added tacoma washington right
outside seattle
july 29th through the 31st las vegas
nevada i'll be doing the grand opening
of wise guys in las vegas
nevada this is for the locals this ain't
on the strip it's right outside it's in
a great little area
that is the new new wise guys in las
vegas nevada
august 12th through the 14th it's gonna
be nice and cool there during then so
that's fun
rally north carolina august 19th to the
21st
san jose california san jose improv
september 9th through the 11th uh
then we'll have san antonio the 24th and
25th then denver september 30th to
october 2nd just added honolulu hawaii
tickets just went on sale
october 29th through the 30th that's
gonna be a fun one but tickets are on
sale at
thickboy.com you can find tickets there
or the traditional f-a-t-k-z
dot-com get you some you guys good oh
yeah
yeah we're good man are we good jen are
you good you got the hawaiian is it from
yeah oh yeah it's like casual friday
right yes
this is more dressing up for you that's
not good it's really it's this that's
dressing down
dressing down yeah cause it's like more
relaxed
no you look way better what things
usually just wear t-shirts
sometimes that would be dressing down
the t-shirt be dressing down again
yeah okay just felt like you're feeling
it yeah today
just today let it be filled all right
thank you because
you felt like it was a casual friday no
because we're going to korean barbecue
i'm happy good mood uh 7 30 30
ish you're going to go or no i don't
know man i know man
you know
did you invite him ahead of time or is
this yeah yeah yeah we changed the day
oh wow let's go thursday at 5 00 yeah oh
i can't go no no we'll change
that one yeah yeah now kyle can't come
are you going to
go oh yeah could you fly out tonight
yeah see what you did there yeah
are you going chiba no we're going home
you're going to phoenix sounds like
there's yeah like an extra spot maybe
yeah it's too extra yeah that's cool
okay seriously yeah so me and my fat ass
yeah i'll reserve two seats for it is it
gonna be different because last time i
went to quarters
hey koreatown was popping under the
middle it's still popping
but it's popping but is it still the
same setup yeah i think it's the same
but then you can actually go inside and
yeah and no mass too so koreans were not
afraid of kobet
i mean not down there they were yeah
that place was just like a like a
festival
it was worse than before it was more
crowded than before my first racism is
fantastic oh yeah wait what happened
yeah i went up to get to the bathroom
and there's like a group of korean guys
yeah i heard they go there's a lot of
white people around here oh [ __ ]
i was like this big white [ __ ]
that's great
and you love seeing that asian guy with
dreadlocks oh yeah there's an asian dude
with dreadlocks yeah
i've seen that before really yep yeah
it's so funny graham he's gonna get
canceled what i know i was gonna say
does he work there or something i don't
remember he was a random guy
yeah i couldn't stop staring at him i
can't even i'm trying to picture an
asian with dreadlocks
insane really it's funny that's a lot of
work it's fantastic like you you want to
have a little texture to your hair so
asian hair would be the
the toughest to make dreadlocks i assume
asians have thick hair right
uh thick straight hair yeah straight
straight very straight yeah
but uh with dreads don't you have to put
some sort of wax in it
and not wash it because they usually
smell like chocolate dreads work
yeah i think it's patchouli right olives
reds smell like see jeremy lin that's
not dress is it
i mean the top part yeah dreads yeah
that looks cool but the commitment to
dreads i mean as you're saying
i don't wash my hair for a few days and
i'm like [ __ ] this stinks yeah yeah
it's like greasy and just like
especially because we work out so yeah
i don't watch my hair after one day like
jesus i remember like a girl who like
smoked a lot of weed like and
didn't wash her hair i guess had like
like the blunt smell like wasn't it
it was like tobacco and i'm like a lot
of times in your hair that's how they
you know if you fail drug tests through
the hair follicles right that's the
longer that's
it's also if you've been with a girl who
smokes it's just like in their it's in
their nails
yeah like their fingers smell like
cigarettes their hair their car
yeah everything smells like cigarettes
it's a grosser smell than that sorry to
anyone who smokes but
but awesome
most people hear now jewel instead does
[ __ ] that's true that's what we have
does your dad smoke cigarettes
no um
the asian man squatting you know in a
deep squat position asians
definitely change smoke a lot yeah yeah
we're only squatting around
yeah i have a cigarette if i'm like if
i'm drunk i'll like
have a cigarette here and there who
taught you that yeah
i started smoking cigarettes from you
like when i'm like really drunk yeah
yeah give me that thing
yeah yeah because honestly why not at
that point yeah
that's pretty pretty common what jersey
you want you're doubling down on the
hockey huh
i've i've worn like four jerseys since
i've been here what jersey is that
that's homeboy that's the stud
yeah well mexican i ordered this like
four weeks ago when it came in yesterday
it just came
is it a triple x no this is normal size
is it really you ordered that from
justin these these look legit
misspelled on the back
is this trey young on the back it's a
hockey damn dog my bad man they got
confused
we'll get you another one
might say greek freak on the back uh
that's about though
yeah that's really that's the cavalry
hockey jerseys are interesting because
they're just
the right size is just incredibly
oversized right well because
so the shoulders are built like this
because and it's long because
it's meant to have shoulder pads under
it so yeah but for some reason it sort
of looks like
like a football jersey looks less small
to me than a hockey jersey because
they're more tight-fitting
yeah yeah jersey uh hockey hockey
dresses yeah is that an east coast thing
a lot of people wear
uh hockey jerseys there's some pretty
fashionable ones the best ones the
old-school uh chicago black octo
the actual indian on it can't get any
more but no yeah you can okay
yeah that's dicey to find it no chicago
blackhawks they still sell their jerseys
they will never change their name bring
that [ __ ] up chin go to chicago
blackhawks jersey uh-huh
they can still rock the blackhawk
because you know the indians can't use
uh
i think his name is benny yeah they
tried saying something
to the uh i don't know who it was on the
blackhawks like yeah we're not we're not
changing our names that's the best
jersey right there this one yeah
they said they weren't the names this
one
that one toast i swear to god
brenda do you own hockey jerseys uh i
have a hockey jersey our boy gave us
uh that says koreatown on it it looks
like i got dumbfounded yeah yep
dumbfounded gave me one
um i had a dope toronto
me and my brother try i think it's at my
dad's house the
toronto maple leafs when i i either
fought and tr
yeah i fought in toronto i fought matt
mitrione there they gave me like an
authentic toronto maple leaf jersey it
was so sick yeah you can't find it who
was on it
it was my name oh that's i think it was
so sick i don't know what's that
it's it's heartbreaking oh well but
those jerseys
i hate that's always your favorite items
[ __ ] disappear you know who rocks him
is uh
homeboy from jay and silent bob kevin
smith kevin
smith is on the chicago yeah maple
leaves
this this one i like this they're the
capitals normal home jersey's kind of
boring these are
this year they did like a bunch of
reverse retro jerseys which like they
did them for all the teams they're old
home jerseys they just
reinvented like they like reversed it
and then like that these are
fire yeah it's just the the sleeves you
pull it off
the sleeves are a little weird they're
long yeah
oh so even though it's your size the the
sleeves go past your
because again like lucky again like you
have elbow pads on trolling patches yeah
so what kind of stuff but when you buy
an
nfl jersey it's not like you can get the
authentic authentic one which
relax they're like four hundred dollars
but then they also have
they have the cut for you just to rock
it in the streets
yeah he needs to do that like i don't
need the baggies sleeves
yeah i ordered this like a little
smaller like because i was hoping it
would be
what is the size i have no idea like
medium or something like that
because i wanted it to be and it's just
still like a little too long i've never
seen a tight hockey jersey like
snug fit yeah yeah no you never want
that like i just meant like they wanted
a tight like on my like
no they're soft though yeah they're dope
does it like i say yeah you pull it off
baseball's my favorite though
yeah baseball changes that rock the [ __ ]
everyone in the bay rocks baseball
jersey i love baseball jerseys
and you actually like you said somebody
confused you for baseball you actually
kind of
like more than most people that i see
you fill it out well and have a frame
for a baseball jersey whereas most
people kind of like
you'll see a skinny dude wearing it and
it's like yeah you don't really know
no did you look at that dog just seeing
what's up man
no you excited to go to phoenix yeah i'm
chilling you just gonna see your family
mm-hmm
she's gonna chill with the fan the white
folks the black folks
you see both chassis do they get along
do you ever bring them together oh
that's not funny
right do they know each other yeah is
that the plot of a funny holiday movie
i don't write this one like that called
squirrel conan is that a great i would
never
oh
i would never write anything like that
i'm not saying you have to write it i
could
no i couldn't do it but yeah they all
know each other they're all cool but
that's not what we asked yeah i'd love
to get them together
oh have you ever brought them together
like that oh you said they know each
other i'm saying do they get along you
know the
the first time i ever performed in
arizona mm-hmm they
came yeah they were all there they sit
on separate sides or
is it like divorced parents like my
parents like i do shows
end of september and uh denver my
parents either because they're divorced
so they come to
separate shows like my mom come to the
early morning late and if they do come
the same show
like my dad's in front my mom's in the
back oh
no it's not like that at all no no it's
never no
because i'm cool as [ __ ] that's why yeah
that's what's up like i don't bring like
weird
i'm pretty cool too but they just don't
get along you know there's a lot of yeah
but they don't have a history of not
getting along
my son drew this when my dad was in town
last week uh he was
mad at something i don't know some you
know kid some stupid so he drew he's
really into drawing right now so he drew
a picture
of me with a happy face i mean i guess
it looked like me then you were like a
mad sad face
he's like this is you right now you
should try and go more over here wow he
can't hit you with the [ __ ] visuals
i started laughing and my dad goes you
know what's funny he did the same thing
and
like everybody's around him like i think
he goes yeah at his age when me and your
mom are getting a divorce
you drew me as the devil and then
with the smiley face oh my god i was
like
that's not the same pull that up that is
super dark
that is super dark and also very sad
hashtag trauma yeah also very sad
we should probably talk to a therapist
about it you as a devil he's like yeah
and then you do you in the corner with
like tears out of your eyes i'm like not
the same
damn he drew this because i didn't give
him a piece of candy
this is super deep and we should
probably talk about somewhere else
yo your dad caught me off guard when i
first met him he gave me that
the way he shook my hand yeah i did not
like we recreated real quick
he was like he was like he went like
this
that was like and he gave the hug and i
was like he's all right stay cool daddy
and then didn't he say like thug life or
something he said he's live something
like that yeah
it really caught me off guard because i
went in with the normal like hey just
you know as a respectful handshake
did he whisper black lives matter to you
you know what i got your dog i'm with
you dogs seeking this [ __ ]
i see this [ __ ] too dawg i've been
watching the tv man [ __ ] up
i told you when he saw derek post him
for the first time in denver he was in
the green room he's like damn man you
like chillin
i was like what is happening now
[Applause]
it just caught me off guard i would have
done it you know like but i just didn't
know he was that's what he was going for
i was just like oh nice to meet you
it looked normal to me you know but yeah
i was like oh you know what this
is i assumed he was going to do it oh
you did you already knew
you like jayla's doing that he's
aggressive that's real aggressive oh
it's so much fun
if they eat chitlins it was hard yeah
it was well it's like that i think it
was the you said he had
a bunch of black friends yeah yeah but
it's like one step away from saying like
you like watermelon
you eat fried chicken yeah like it's not
quite there did you see that
uh that guy i think it was in ikea for
that uh june 19th
you know he decided to sell it junete
to celebrate it he was giving out free
fried chicken and watermelon
but it was a white guy doing it didn't
go over
yeah it's a little just condescending
just yeah
you know you're not fully racist at
least condescending speaking of chicken
i went to popeyes in the hood last night
yeah off of the bread bro there's no
wall cups
and they had they like pushed your food
out they like thrown at you yeah
because i didn't realize it you know
when you see when you see it built up
like that that's when you realize
oh you're in a tough area yeah they're
doing that for a reason they just didn't
wear like okay let's make sure we don't
deal with anything
yeah exactly exactly they started doing
like it's literally like
uh like the plexiglass there's like a
window like this yeah yeah yeah
you can't you can't even see them really
okay wasn't it really chaotic when the
chicken sandwich
wasn't there like fights breaking out in
popeyes have you had it
i have not oh that's good it's delicious
but i wouldn't fight no one over it
no i sure as [ __ ] wouldn't shake i mean
i fought people over you know
that [ __ ] but yeah i wouldn't fight so
actually i did try to fight someone with
a chicken sandwich definitely that's
when you're young
yeah drinking when i was drunk it was a
wild turkey night well you know you know
the reason nike create their
their sneaker app and don't do the drops
in store anymore because people are
like getting killed for it like young
people getting [ __ ] up yeah yeah
that's stupid lord of the flies i mean
you put people together and it's like
all right everybody we're going for this
thing
correct quickly people just like crap i
mean it's it's a good sandwich but it's
not like
it's not better chick-fil-a put you in a
headlock [ __ ]
or owl's
was that the spot you had last night
yeah this is nashville hot bro
i saw you post about it what was it was
better or worse than helen race i know
better or worse than hella race it's
is the best nashville chicken hot
sandwich in the country
destroys nashville destroys any i don't
give a [ __ ] where you've had chicken
sandwiches destroys that
al's is like if if holland raises a 10
al's is like a 9.5 what about
convenience because sometimes i don't
feel like getting helen raised because
it's you have to jump through so many
ways that's my problem with helen right
yeah like just give me a [ __ ]
sandwich dude
and then do they still do the holland
raids where you gotta
order it first and then uber and then
the on postmates yeah it's
[ __ ] annoying oh so it's a whole
process to get it it's a nightmare yeah
only on post base who came up with yeah
and then and then you have to do it
like i'm right here like there you go
and then there's like that's what we are
feet yeah it's so strange al's no way
you just
is that out by you though it's by him
yeah that's like a boss i don't
go see it yeah yeah it's great no does
it tear your [ __ ] not no if you go
really hot it's gonna give you
gums but i go mild and their mild's
[ __ ] hot okay i've had they're hot
and it's worse in hell and raised really
way worse you actually have to like sign
this form before you order it oh [ __ ]
yeah and i was like oh they're saying
it was tough well he destroyed the plane
one time we were coming from nashville
could you smell it could you smell from
your seat yeah because he brought he had
to bump me
he was like hey dog i gotta get sleeping
i'm like bro we just took off like we
literally
didn't matter are still extending and
the mean cat ate these this special i
forget where it was from but it was like
this super hot hot my
my yeah my wing was purple it was like
you know what i did so hot purple we
went to
uh that was uh prince yeah i think it
was hot chicken or something like that
that one was good too
wait did it tear cash it up
yeah i was in charlotte because i was
filming a few commercials for eckrich
meets and ended up doing another spot
for
me weber girls what's up baby i did one
last year it was super fun where i'm
like barbecuing and making some uh
like sausage on the grill doing like a
little recipe it's a funny little
commercial
i did a coors light commercial on
tuesday
and it's funny because i have to like
they're like all my stuff was done by
like 2 30 and they're like
i'm like cool someone catch this 10
o'clock flight like actually we need you
to stick around till 9 00 pm and i did
nothing from 2 30 to nine but they just
have you around
that's actually gotta like switch just
in case just in case and they cut you
had to switch by flight get on like a
midnight flight head to north carolina
north carolina was super cool had a lot
of fun that's uh the owner of the
ad agency right there she's owner of
anchorage no not owner of eckrich uh she
has the
um trophy agency yeah so i got it i got
to do one day film a couple funny spots
and they kind of know me now
i don't think my ads on there it's on my
page yeah those hot dogs
are fantastic and uh [ __ ] hey
if yeah if you scroll down a few rows
it's a while back um
and yeah then they were like all right
we shot this one let's do like an oh if
you can stick around tomorrow
there it is yeah in the middle right
there it's hilarious eat big
to get big here's one of my favorite
bulking meals using equity
haters say i'm not an absolute sausage
fanatic
i never skipped my veggies either and
now for my favorite part
a little ecbridge smoked sausage in
there a little more
a little more acrid smoked sausage is a
great source of protein and it cooks
even faster so
you can get back to the gym wow that was
yeah real hundred pound weight right
there
not fake at all on a budget it does look
nice
so yeah so you didn't pay hello and i i
would assume coors is
more financially the big the big the big
dog you want those just because
ever yeah yeah and it's also like union
versus none if you get a union
commercial
like every so the one next to it the cdw
one i think you guys have played that
before but like
people have been blowing me up about
that one playing um
during like the nhl semifinals and like
like do you get paid when it's
aired on those two or just yeah every so
with the non-union they basically buy
like they pay you a session fee and then
they buy you out if it
ends up playing somewhere so it's like
you know you get this much money and
then
and that much money like once it hits
the air but just a one-time lump
then who monitors that your manager your
agent if because yes
yeah yeah they have to and they they're
pretty good because it's a union thing
like
um well for the cdw one that's the
office wonder i'm like hitting a dude
and saying you're in for a brood
awakening
oh all right here we go
that one's been playing all over i guess
so people keep hitting me i'll just show
you and i'm like yes because every time
somebody says that i'm like money money
money money money
that's good that played i've watched one
game it played
i think every time there was a
commercial break that commercial played
yeah so i'm psyched about that just
because it's like you know and it's also
just
funny like that was a fun shoot i got to
do like all these different lines and
smack the [ __ ] out of this
dude like i felt bad because the dude's
like he's like a small dude
and the black guy you're in for it no
this dude comes
like that was the mildest thing we did
they had me like uppercutting him and
like lifting off the ground like a
couple times i'm like
i think i just broke this dude's face
like oh [ __ ] me my girl
so we watched [ __ ] yellowstone for
the third time all
these seasons and then we have where you
have no shows to watch so we're running
game of thrones back
nice we start with game of thrones how
the [ __ ] have you not been in game of
thrones i don't know
what do you want perfect for game of
thrones i would love to do something
like that [ __ ] perfect for amazon
um well i don't have that much serious
stuff in my role if you want to go to
you want to see a serious role here okay
go to um winter's coming
youtube seven dust music video seven
destiny oh yeah
[Applause]
this if you google them it should be the
latest music video they put out yeah
their most recent one there it is
they're on my facebook
so we can't play the music but you wanna
just watch it first sure
man the summer is here and you're in the
gym you're getting in
shape you're ditching that quarantine 30
you put on like your boy here and you're
doing everything right
but you like to sip on some cold ones
but you don't want all the calories
that's your carbs the sugar
what are you going to do you want to
reach for a cold one well then core said
hold on
literally hold my bear cause we got
cores pure that's right
course pure you're working out hard
you're trying to eat healthy you're
trying to keep up with the wellness
trends of the day you're doing all that
well now get it with your beer new
new course pure is refreshingly simple
beer with organic barley
organic hops water 92 calories and
zero sugar zero freaking sugar man
zero so you can drink some of those bad
boys and they're delicious
and you're not gonna crush your diet
with that stuff man and it's going to
give you the fix that you're looking for
coarse pure is the perfect bear
to celebrate the winds of life every day
so when you want to enjoy a beer
without the guilt reach for coarse pure
it's organic but they're chill about it
no up in your face like
organic no they're not that man go to
course pure.com
see where you can find coors pure
celebrate responsibly coors
brewing company albany georgia
we'll just play the music like low let's
see see mark's uh
facial expressions you'll understand
what he's doing do you guys
audition for this mark no actually i was
doing this as a favor to a buddy
they didn't pay me but he was like hey
want to be a music video i'm kind of
like sure
i'm sure it'll suck but let's do it and
then end up being this really dope
music video and the director i'll show
you something else because it's
this is another little funny thing
because the director is like ukrainian
and his wife is this youtube fitness
star like russian language fitness star
and they're like hey do you wanna watch
me yeah
yeah i mean game of thrones if they
bring back a new season because uh the
newest season is going to be
the targaryens and they're known for
their silver hair i don't see why mark
couldn't what's up dude come on get
me yeah or what's the anarchy
so yeah the director was like hey do you
want to do this my wife has this like
russian language fitness app do you want
to do like look at these workouts
so that also just dropped and they put
it on this the page for the app and i'm
like explaining like the tabata like hit
workouts and it's all dubbed in russia
so it's like i saw that my name is mark
i want to do personal trends
how about our boy from platesmore dates
broke down you describing uh
steroids yeah that was really cool
because i love that guy
yeah he was awesome and it was cool to
see that um
you know he basically agreed with what i
said and went into some more nuance
which of course it's hard to
go into you know too much nuance but i
was worried he was going to light you up
but you know that's like what was real
derek
derek yeah i don't know his last name
but yeah this is one of my favorite
youtube channels and i think a great
resource for anybody because he goes
into like
the pharmacology and chemistry of it all
and not just steroids also like
you know hair loss and stuff like that
my understanding of like oh
he takes he goes it's sort of like a
general male male improvement but like
one of the big things does he
shoot it out of a trailer park no i feel
like this dude's got like a million subs
that's a little ac in the background i
don't know but it's like
is he in a trailer park home i think
maybe a studio
is because i'm sure he's doing really
good yeah he's doing great
he has a regular job too and he's wicked
smart yeah so smart and
he's out of canada somebody yeah yeah
man somebody you go if you want to go
balls deep into the science of it and of
course like
i'm trying to keep up i don't know all
the science of it i don't retain it all
but it gives you an idea i've learned a
lot of nuance
um about both anabolics hair loss and
stuff like that like and exactly like
okay what's finasteride doing what's
minoxidil doing
what are um you know other compounds
like uh
you know i learned about ru 58441 all
these like experimental things that are
like not for human use but you can buy
them and you know
can you imagine having him as a resource
as when you're kid in high school or
college
no it's crazy you're trying to dabble in
like right you know it's like when we
were younger like
the forums on bible nobody knows
anything people were just like
and they're all just a thousand
milligrams of this right we'll see how
it goes
yeah that that to me that's like the
definition of bro science is just going
this guy did this and then it creates an
echo chamber of commerce
yeah nobody's looking into the science
of it so if you want like nuanced
scientific perspective him this other
guy vigorous steve
who's like this um he's from holland and
he's a bodybuilder
he's like a coach who goes really in
depth but also
in depth because then i zone out not
really because yeah that's why i like
this guy it's not like it's deep but
it's awesome yeah
i'm gonna have to have you not bored in
engineering what i would say he does
vigorous steve goes balls deep but he
gives great advice anytime somebody
comes to me with like beginner questions
a lot of time i'll recommend them to him
because he goes
um like he has specific videos on like
if you're a beginner here the
compounds you should stick to and his
whole approach is like i've coached
hundreds of people
and this is the absolute safest way to
do it and his his recommendations are
like start with them
for like workouts for like specific
workouts
now he'll talk about workouts too but i
think you know
a lot of this like he's a great
bodybuilder and he has opinions on that
i think it's like but
as far as resources on youtube where you
can go because what are the common
questions like i've talked about that i
get it's mostly people with
sort of entry-level questions super you
know
like i'm taking sarms or i'm doing this
my buddy said do this
and i try to steer him in the right
direction of like what's the general
principle
lowest effective dose start with
bioidentical hormones like
you know like i said hgh test and
insulin don't use insulin if you don't
have somebody coaching you
people jump on me for that i'm like but
you can use it
if you have somebody like vigorous steve
coaching and monitoring you it can be
you safely but don't just
that's not something to experience i'd
love for chin to get on some [ __ ]
yeah dude you would be so big what's
your interest in that chin
pretty damn high i've been talking about
it what what are you saying i don't know
what'd you think she goes he'd be so big
and like maybe i think i'd be just gonna
when i started lifting when i was
younger i got big yeah like really big
that'd be sick people think people think
i'm on it you look like correct
you'll see a lot of you need a deal you
will see a lot of comments about
like you know so on this video in
particular there was comments like
um i can't believe chappelle or the the
black guy
who's obviously on juice says to use
know anything about juice
ha ha i'm like like this i would just i
don't know you
i would just say it all right what the
[ __ ] do i have that because there's a
whole industry around podcasting
punk rock like we said before there's a
whole industry of people who
can't say that they're on anything so
there's this big assumption that
everybody who's jacked is lying
oh god of course you're an elite athlete
yeah i don't think i know
because i mean like i obviously like i'm
new to this [ __ ] workout
super so it's like i'm not [ __ ] but
people you saw games really fast like
yeah you know
you were like you were like i did 185 me
like so like people just think that's
impossible
yeah they're just without without they
didn't do it themselves that's really
what it is
if you're weak and you haven't had good
results for whatever reason shouldn't
you tell you that
you're lazy as [ __ ] but like for example
you guys know larry wheels
the dude he's in a wheelchair
no i think it's a nickname but it's not
he's got a lot of
records for um he's a super big jack
black guy and like
a power lifter with insane numbers like
dead lifts i think close
to 900 pounds um benches
and maybe close to 700 i want to say
like well over six hundred
stupidity and also open about his his
usage and
you know be like i take test and anadra
and and i tried this yeah i don't know
you don't be open i can just go ahead
and get it
was like he was as jacked as
i know right no you're looking at this
and go this guy takes [ __ ]
you know nothing i would say crazy but
like he's open about what he said
and has just insane strength even for
how big he is
he's a level of strength what would he
weigh maybe
was he 270 maybe oh yeah somewhere
around there i think he's competed at
240 maybe but people cut down
but his numbers are just you know insane
so anyway
you look at you hear his life story and
you're like oh at
however young he was at 16 you already
know your elite
if you if you can get online and see
what other people are doing you're like
oh
i can bench 400 and i'm 17 years old he
has these videos of him like
at like 18 like repping [ __ ] you know
seven plates on the deadlift and it's
just like
oh yeah you're so he's six one he's he's
taylor between 245
308 he must have been super juicy and i
think that's the weight clown i don't
think he actually weighs
oh that's the route but that's he the
lowest he's been high 240 weight class
and he's has a number of records there
he walks around 270-ish yeah he's 255
now yeah he's 6-1-255 yeah that's a big
boy
yeah like i've seen him overhead press
um
at least four plates maybe up to 455
like standing overhead press
which is did you see homeboy in the gym
today i don't know if you i think we're
doing the lunges with the
135. do you see the four plates on the
shoulder press
more oh the black dude i didn't see him
lifted but i saw him on there
yeah holy [ __ ] he got two but it was
[ __ ] that's
bananas because that machine is actually
pretty hard it's a nice little rep with
like two plates and that's a lot yeah
he's probably all natty
yeah yeah why else on your head like
that wait okay okay
no i'm being dead serious because i
don't care i don't even know it like
that
so you just assume everybody's natural
because i go the opposite
oh you go to opposites oh yeah yeah dude
you look at what they're doing and when
they tell me all that i'm like hell yeah
that's great yeah
you look at what they're doing to me
maybe with rare exceptions you can be
like competing
in like the fit or whatever the the
lower level before classic and open
bodybuilding there's like the board
short level
physique even those guys man no those
guys are on juice you could pull it off
and you could like get in the
competition being maddy with freak
genetics but
even at that level no um yeah if a guy
says
they're competing in bodybuilding
they're dabbling in the even if it's a
natural competition i'd be like what are
they testing are they testing out
at the competition i thought it was
gonna be out for the bodybuild the the
one with the board shorts uh
there's also there's natty content you
would assume like and i could just show
you examples of guys like
you would more so they look shredded and
maybe a little bit smaller and more
normal on stage because they're like
dried out super lean if you look at
those guys like bulking in the off
season you could be
oh those are big [ __ ] dudes like i
would look small compared to of course
i'd be taller than most of them but like
i'm not even as big as a lot of these
dudes like in the off season
you know so would you ever compete you
have the genetics for it
no because you know why you're posing
to be like dude you're doing a worm in
the
fog oh brook he did it right today
go to my story uh chin it would maybe be
funny to do
i just you know what's oh there is a
level of like
do i need to be less than ten percent
body fat like i just don't
you know it's like it's gonna be a beast
yeah i'd rather just know at a certain
level
um now i i admire the best bodybuilders
and think it's a grind it's super tough
like you have to have
just cheeked up right there yeah
this is cheesy
um would i compete i've thought about it
before and then i'm kind of like
just the effort that it like the
difference is
like i i know i'd be capable of doing it
it's just do you want to be that guy
who's like
here's what i ate today and yeah cutting
and i'm on weekend i'm eight weeks out
and posting all these
like i just would rather be like a
certain level of buff i'm okay with this
yeah you know i'd rather be a
personality in the space than like
actually compete right yeah yeah no same
and i just think also that's for like
the
you know there's not a lot of money
unless you're like the top of the top
unless you're mr olympia
unless you're it's not super lucrative
so i think people have it right
like a guy like um i'm blanking on his
name but he played arnold in that
documentary bigger um i know people can
give me [ __ ] for forgetting his name but
uh he's an australian caitlyn von monger
von mugger he played sportsnaker yeah
and he's got an amazing
like does he does he competes a little
bit but like um
colin von yeah caleb von mooger
sorry that i butchered his name caleb
but let's get let's see some images of
him
great physique holy crap you know
and he's got the look he's got but he
doesn't he's not putting everything
similar
arnold's physique yeah and so he played
him he did and he actually checks
not as good though nobody's chat you
know it's like
no he looks great that's him now he lost
weight
you know he had something when he like
he like tore his quad doing rock
climbing he did like some
like two-person deadlift or no they he
did a two-person
curl with like they took like 405 and
they like you stood next to a buddy and
they tried to curl it and his bicep tour
so he's like [ __ ] himself up with
stupid
like instagram he was jacked and now
he's all thin
i don't think he's he started gaining
again but there are like you'll see some
like okay i had quad and bicep surgery
i'm not really lifting heavy
yeah you know but you can also cut
that's an example of like
his hair out still a dime piece yeah so
what i'm saying is
amazing genetics and physique but he's
not like
competing year-round yeah you know he's
a personality and and putting his eggs
in that
basket of of uh you know uh fitness
influencing
goddamn daddy you know from don private
but if you want to see somebody so do
you know um chris bumstead
he's the current classic uh physique
champion so that's
classic physique is defined by like you
can weigh a certain amount per your
height so this dude's actually a little
bit
taller but this is like because a lot of
people criticize
open bodybuilders for being too big so
he's kind of got more of a like you know
the 70s 80s yeah still gigantic yeah the
olympia now they're almost
almost like mutants like because yeah
hgh has been introduced
yeah okay you go back to like arnold and
the
the old school guys they weren't [ __ ]
with hgh and insulin levels
they really had to get this to a few
yeah and they didn't have like the power
gut where
right gh people think he just grows
muscles no girls yeah their heads are
all big and your intestines are guts
everything grows big so that's where you
get that power gut intestinal those guys
don't have that back
to me they look so much better that guy
looks [ __ ] great
yeah so i think that's as far as
aesthetics
that's an interesting little you know
zone of like i don't need his
inspirational quotes but that's fine
he said power gut yeah you seen the
power gap
uh-huh they all have to hit a vacuum
which they don't in um
yeah because so the power got you so on
stage they look insane
yeah but then off season but even if
they turn to the side
it look it's a gut but it's like it's
like a six-pack they look like teenage
mutant ninja turtles yeah
the gut is protruding and that's because
google power gut chin it's
it's very strange because everything
grows
the vacuum is to basically make your
waist as small as possible like arnold
was amazing at this it's just like to
really showcase like
you know the masculine like broad
shoulder big chest
no power gut i know i just changed it on
its own
i work out with this you see it
and that's kind of like the standard
look the standard see that guy flexing
down below there
well there's where is that uh
uh-huh so a lot of these dudes look you
see the guy who's like this jen
yeah so arnold will also troll these
dudes yeah it's like
at the arnold classic he'll like when
kai greene won it he goes
hey let's see you hit the uh uh vacuum
and
he like puts people on the spot but he
acts all nice he's like oh man the
physique looks great like can we just
see you hit a vacuum
for the crowd and then and then they
they can't do it yeah
all right maybe next time arnold's such
a great troll
you ever see the words that person that
kid tried to drop kick arnold
oh yeah yeah south africa or something
dude
like that right for the gram yeah and i
don't know
it's like moving around no it's arnold
man yeah
look at that so anyway do i have an
interest in getting on us
you know in a speed on cutting down i
admire those guys
you know what i'm saying okay maybe on a
dare now that you bring it up i know
right yeah i feel like you just won that
would be yeah
you do okay that would be maybe fun to
do once
just record it you know see what's up do
a youtube series off
yeah you might give first place put my
money where my mouth is
it's possible depending on how shitty
the competition is but um
yeah i just think it's such a beast to
get ready for that it's a lot of money
to do it
yeah well a lot of work right not a lot
of people it's just your life kind of
has to revolve around that and i
i'm not super familiar i know there's
like techniques of like water and salt
loading and
the entire process leading up to the
show to essentially we'd have to fight
yourself
out yeah that would be interesting to do
that to learn all those i want to learn
those it's just
i can't coach anybody i know how to get
lean but it's like to get contest ready
lean
there's different specific protocols
that literally you're trying to vacate
water from your body
to have the you know not only the lowest
body fat but essentially dehydrate
yourself as well but dehydrate and then
and then they eat carbs that right
before right because that goes right
into your muscles
and your glycogen loads yeah
but you can't if you miss time that then
it's going to spill over and you know so
there's a science to
looking your best on stage it isn't
healthy right
you're putting your body through some
really unhealthy [ __ ]
um like a yo-yo diet yeah and then you
about it's you know a lot of people do
the diet and then they gain
20 pounds the next day so people like uh
greg gusetz another
channel that i go to and he talks about
that he's like don't you know if you're
doing a bodybuilding show
don't like go nuts and have 30 doughnuts
the next day he's like gradually
reintroduce food because
you're going to throw that all away you
know you don't want to just like die
down to six percent body fat
once just the journey and document it
that'd be dope
yeah that's a tough gig man no because
i'm saying don't you have to pay to
enter those
competitions a lot i believe so yeah
yeah that's why it's nothing crazy oh
yeah
it's not expensive yeah the discipline
is insane those
those guys are so disciplined man this
dude's one of my favorites um greg
ducette he's really
somebody who i got interested in because
he has a high voice like that
that's his voice people he's like
trademark is his voice he kind of rants
like the uh
but is there a difference like the
toucan
in what's that movie oh for liking
yeah yeah exactly um
what is so he has a really like i think
he's good for
like beginners to intermediates he has a
lot of great wisdom without getting
bogged down too much in the science he
has great like recipe ideas
because he's a dude who like i've been
trying to tell brendan because your idea
of like dieting like oh i have to go
keto i have to do
this hardcore thing and i'm trying to
you know
tell you oh you can as you've been
tracking your macros yeah oh i can
actually
spend way easier eat some eat some more
flexible yeah like last night i had i
had that al's natural hot sandwich i had
900 calories left on my calorie tractor
yeah i looked this up it was like 700 so
i had half of the sandwich
yeah yeah calories so yeah and you don't
feel like oh i'm cutting everything out
right no
and i also didn't you know purge or
nothing like that right after yeah
question i don't know is there like a
like when people say you're not supposed
to eat past a certain time is that a
real thing too depends on your goals
yeah you know
okay there's benefits to fasting right
and if it's for you like fasting's not
right everyone either
the the the biological benefit that
people preach is like autophagy like
your cells like
killing off the old cells you know which
has a benefit to you
if you're just talking purely dieting
yeah i would just
put that under there's more than one way
to skin a cat if fasting helps you eat
less calories
right because you could fast for 16
hours a day and then eat
10 000 calories in an hour and a day you
know yeah but
if you start fasting and you don't let's
say you don't eat breakfast you don't
need to like one
yeah i found myself like when dinner
came around it was i mean i was [ __ ]
those goats
famished yeah yeah so i would say it it
would suit does it suit your lifestyle
or not
um another guy do you mind if i bring
this up uh
kino body gregor gallagher he just
really the guy you showed me with the
calories and stuff yes
so i showed brendan this guy's video to
demonstrate a flexible dieting
lifestyle this guy's naturally youtube
is a great physique he's built a really
interesting brand kind of based off a
lot of things that i believe in like
training minimalism he sticks to the
basics reverse pyramids
you know only a few days a week for guys
who like you know his message is like
you don't have to spend all day in the
gym
you can eat a flexible diet you he eats
chipotle
like every day uses fasting
um and i showed brendan this video where
he goes like yeah i start my day
i break my fast with a rice krispie
treat and i think he ends it with a
chocolate bar but in between he's eating
enough protein and getting other
macronutrients
it's just that he doesn't have to cut
out these things that he likes he
doesn't have five chocolate bars
yeah he doesn't have ten rice krispie
treats but he hasn't beat himself
up over the chocolate bar correct and so
his whole model is like um he also lives
in a mansion
he also lives in a mansion yeah uh he
also is kind of it's interesting because
a lot of people will kind of like poo
poo the idea of like
i'm training for aesthetics most guys if
you really ask them are training for
aesthetics so one of part of his message
is like hey you want to look like
the hollywood physique that people like
tell you is you know the movie stars are
doing whatever
focus on this focus on your shoulders
and your upper chest and you know
you know you don't have to have huge
bulky legs and you know maybe train
upper body twice and lower body
once you know a week so again natty
he gets to around six percent body fat
and
um that's what i want with the idea in
mind of like yeah you want to get girls
like you don't have to be a mutant huge
dude
you know super jacked on juice if that's
what you want to do great but
um a lot of guys kind of find that
philosophy of minimalism
um and you know flexible dieting
interesting
that's him on a yacht that's him yeah
yeah so
he saw that i was wearing a uh one of
his henleys the other week and gave me a
shout out and asked
um do i have any suggestions for his
clothing and i said look
right now the biggest size is xl why
would he do that i just feel like it's
hurtful to a lot of people in this room
yeah i mean yes is it all tight like is
this one of his t's yeah this is one of
his t's we're all tight like this that's
an xo
this is an xl oh come on it's time but
not too tight right sort of like
it hangs well tell not to do that either
[Laughter]
my comment was when the haters say i
look bad in my keno henley on the
fighter and the kitchen
so greg if you're watching can we get
some double xls
at least yeah what are we doing
i know xl who only offers xl
even lululemon offers double come on hug
yeah
they do yeah right don't lose don't
discriminate greg
don't discriminate what's that i go i
got some new lulu are you wearing them
now
no no because you make fun of them
really
yeah you said these they had some new
pants i see you got the g-pants yeah
they look like jujitsu it's a long just
wide leg
i like blue lemons i just don't tell
anybody that i have them you know why
you say that because there's a lot of
people because it's a
lot of a lot of baggage about you know
like if you're a guy wearing lululemon
yeah
i don't [ __ ] with anything there's just
comfortable pants they are i'm just
saying i don't know
yeah i just see it not being worn i
guess i'll try it on yeah do it
you never wear hats no i never wear that
your pops wears hats
you look just like your dad right now
yeah i don't know why you don't wear
them yeah
that's one of my favorite hats it's your
birthday
we're going to party oh you do look like
you said holy [ __ ] you think
yeah with the hat something about the
shadow on his head
it looks like my friend 50 yeah
what
[Applause]
okay so john mcafee uh
was found dead in a prison cell the
other day and
people are now equating his
death which was ruled as a suicide as a
murder similar to
uh epstein because there was a tweet two
years ago where he said that yeah from
him saying
i would never kill myself if i happen to
pop up
i'm dead and people say it's a suicide
it's not i was whacked
and he believed it so much that he also
got a tattoo that said
whacked on that'd be a great troll
though if you're planning on committing
suicide like dude if i ever commit
suicide like it's definitely the cia
wait what the what the [ __ ] was he in
jail for uh he
originally was here he created mcafee
yeah yeah yeah he ended up
leaving the united states because he was
trying to
be i believe he was trying to get
arrested on tax evasion people were
trying to get him here
where did he live he moved to i think he
was in bolivia for a while and he was in
uh belize i don't remember exactly where
he was when he died
but he was in a south american country
before mcphee's death he was due to be
extradited as part of a criminal
investigation into his tax affairs
oh he was found in uh barcelona actually
did he have any
a history of mental illness at all i
don't know
maybe because i'm like what would they
have i love that story but it's like i
want i just want like
because you're making that big of a deal
out of it you know i just john mack
scroll down chin there's something on
the right there uh
keep going there it is john mcafee's
instagram post
cue image minutes after his death is
reported weird
so people a lot of people think it's
just another um
murder conspiracy theory yeah but what
what what would matt did he have what
yeah
nothing that's come out to my
understanding that makes it seem like
powerful people are after him it seems
like it's just the tax evasion stuff
yeah yeah because epstein i think
absolutely made that such a
complicated like we know why you'd want
a murderer
if he had all these secrets what would
you want the guy that created the virus
being uh
you know so if he's balls deep in like
that q on queueing on stuff
like that so if i end up dead you know
i mean it sounds a little bit grandiose
sounds like you just commit suicide
yeah what else you got instead of like
you want some attention after death yeah
yeah so conan o'brien is currently going
viral because
on air he smoked a joint with seth rogen
and he only has a few episodes left
before his show
completely ends on what what is it nbc
i think it's tbs on tbs so he has
only has a few shows left and he decided
to smoke a joint on live television
[ __ ] it a lot of people are going either
way to say
uh thank you and like goodbye to conan
right now people i love conan i also
love conan he's so
talented he's by far the funniest one
out of all and a mean guitar player
chen really he's like yeah he's a good
guy super funny
did seth rogen get high and throw his
buddy james franco under the bus or what
uh no that was fun
[Laughter]
yeah he's got a guitar case right there
[Applause]
yeah that's what happens when you're fat
and lose too much weight
without like gaining any muscle
[Laughter]
andy richter
that's so funny good for them
yeah reminds me where's conan is conan's
going somewhere though and he's
podcasting
yeah he's trying to do podcasting on
spotify i don't know
i think he signed a deal with spotify oh
he's signed a deal too his podcasting
stuff is getting pretty popular
okay so a 56 year old man stole a 1.2
million dollar
yacht and he went joyriding for two days
the police officers in that area i
believe it was parked
in new york at a port they found out
that the boat was missing
found the boat then arrested the 56 year
old man
he made up an excuse saying that he
knows the owner of the boat saying that
he this is dan bilzerian's dad that
stole it right
i thought this was crying when he was up
in auburn
[Laughter]
he came up with the excuse that he knows
the owner the owner gave him permission
to
use the bow and that he was going to
drive the boat
to canada where the owner lives but the
owner says i don't know this man he just
stole my yacht
yeah and he was just by himself he had a
bunch of hoes he was just by himself oh
see that's boring
see you should have a party at that
point what a waste of time at least
drive it to
like an island yeah where are you but
then you're stuck on the island
yeah what's the closest island you can
you can get to on
boat from new york though probably in
staten island
yeah that's nice
go to iceland really though supposed to
be really nice though
do you remember this transgender one
this was the and it was a guy that
transitioned to a woman
it's just listen i'm i have no opinion
on this whatsoever
i support transgender 100 yeah but when
it comes to sports it just gets dicey
because olympics not just
born a man felt like a woman right but
you're still
you have the physique of a man they're
competing in 2013 is where she's trent
she transitioned or he transitioned to
her man yeah
[ __ ] i'd be more interested in the the
opinions of the women
that she's of course and they were they
were i don't have my personal opinion on
it either way i just happened to step
back
that person was pretty good when they
were a man too
i don't know about the history well
not not olympic hey man no they weren't
no there's a reason like they were doing
it but i don't think they were
stellar no she wouldn't play not as good
but it's like you know now the i think
the the female deadlift and records were
all broke because it's done by a
transgender
female and then there was that
transgender
uh boy who converted over to female
and started wrestling in high school and
just beat the [ __ ] out of the girls
yeah and then they're telling her she
can't wrestle i don't think that's right
either
so yeah that was interesting because it
was a reverse where she's like i want to
compete against
yes but there's no there's nothing for
her to do it
yes so if they don't let her do that
then why
let you know laurel hubbard do
do this you know what i mean like that's
the well they created a protocol for it
they created a protocol and it was like
you know we could probably look at that
like
um you have to have oh this isn't true
now look at that the international
olympic committee has specific
guidelines for transgender
yeah correct a certain amount of
testosterone levels must be at a certain
exactly
yeah she's met though since 2015 yeah
yeah so she's met that it's just
still has still has the physique of a
man though that's a thing bones and
joints that's where it gets complicated
it's tough muscle mass so you know who
has a great video on this actually
it's more plays more dates yeah i'm sure
you did a great breakdown of like what
the exact science is and why people call
into question
um the fairness of saying it's just
about hormones because again
you're banking myonuclei as a man so you
just have more muscle cells to begin
with which if you bank them they're not
going away um
you know a different ligament and joint
structures bone densities brendan was
saying
um even just the with i always think
about this like
like you can look at someone's like the
broadness of somebody's shoulders right
like you look at brendan
your frame sort of to me isn't
surprising that you can bench
over 400 pounds right if you had really
narrow shoulders or
some other aspects you're just never
going to reach a certain point because
you have these
physical limitations just that you can
sort of go how big you know how tall how
wide how long your arms for deadlifting
certain things
that give you a little bit of an
advantage it's not up to me to say these
things are fair or not
but the gender differences broadly but
they shouldn't not be allowed to compete
they need to come up with some sort of
other yeah people are just going to
cheat for
the requirements yes are those
requirements um
and those other girls are at such a
disadvantage yeah such a distance so
again i would be super interested
here there has to be some sort of weight
i think after time
when she beat out to get that spot after
time there's going to be probably a
category for
yeah there's just not enough yeah it's
just not right now we're just going
through
yeah and by the way they're they're
competing in the 87 kilogram division so
i did the
the hundreds 191 pounds for women's
that's kind of i didn't know that even
existed
and there's not a lot of them though
they're they're
here's another transgender uh runner
that didn't qualify
because uh it's got to be embarrassing
right
it's not for you so her testosterone
levels were not below
five no no mollies or whatever per liter
and then this is her
she won a national championship before
cece telfer
uh-huh and then what happened to
national championship what
so even though i mean but that is a big
leap to go from like oh good now i
assume it wasn't nc oh yeah the oregon
things are there but i don't
was [ __ ] working or different college
i'm not sure is that like is that like a
d3 national championship i mean shout
out to d3 but
like laughing chin because mario's just
going going forward yeah he's trying to
i know he's trying it's a tough talent
right
it's the best i'm going to latch on too
i want to know more more about what is
but that is also an argument in favor of
hey it's not an
automatic yeah you know you're not
automatically just going to transition
and
and uh win the olympic gold exactly
there are some really fast women out
there who will smoke that yeah what's
that girl's name
uh oh the orange hair we said yes yes
yeah she's
she's a [ __ ] beast yeah she beat
alison felix
is it shakara uh orange yeah
[Applause]
yeah it's just right there
okay yeah she's pretty where's the uh
yeah you got to watch the video of her
running
you don't want to see it i mean it's
just them running a straight line you
know
but you got to see her do it you ever
seen it you've never seen hussein bolt
running
but i mean yeah that's that's a given
we're talking about shikari not talking
about you saying
you got a fast footage yeah
she's warming up right now and then she
runs up and hugs her grandma
oh yeah that was sweet allison felix
qualified too got
third it's her fourth olympics
with the other girls in the lead oh she
comes from behind too
there she goes her hair looks [ __ ]
sweet
i heard that like initial like set the
gate yeah i heard it's like tough it's
everything
yeah she cussed yeah she runs it and
sees her
uh grandma
oh because her yeah her mom just had
pass or something yeah her mom
just said pass god what what
4 000 people dislike this what
oh god damn yeah yeah
what went wrong they don't like orange
hair
oh it's very sweet that's sweet
super sweet that's cool
cool okay i look so uncomfortable on the
left
and is that an all-time record or just
the fastest woman right
now i don't know what was that she's now
america's fastest woman
i don't know if it beats marion jones
but i think all her [ __ ] got thrown out
because the background
stuff yeah just had a little yeah a
little
something in the old system what else
you got jen
um let's go with this has been been
going viral i guess this is from 2019
though but have you seen this one
some guy that's just like a white dude
that just is like in he's like intensely
asking someone i want to shake her hand
and he got arrested
because he wants to shake his hands yeah
he was definitely drunk
i'll show you the original video why do
you want to shake his hands up i don't
know there's no there's not like
a good backstory to this
everyone's scared though
i want to shake your hand i'm going to
shake your hand
i'm not drunk i want to shake his hand
you got arrested for this well he was
literally doing something before
now would you feel like would you start
to feel like i'm gonna have to be the
one who entertain this guy yeah 100
do you think especially because i want
to get going too so yeah dude get the
[ __ ] off the plane
yeah no one's shaking because you look
at the okay also quit being the guy who
the guy is
terrifying is pretty small compared to
this dude's got to be over six feet tall
he looks giant yeah
so maybe there was some anti-semitism
going on before oh okay
no i don't i mean that there has to be a
lot there for you i want to shake your
hand
he says an anti-semitic joke and then
he's like i'm just playing around no
that's not me and my friend's joke
yeah and then there's a bunch of remixes
and stuff like that because that's what
they do with viral videos
it's five years old it just came out now
but i guess the video is from 2019.
but it just came viral now yeah how
quickly would you ever choke them out
i just gotta get going yeah yeah yeah
so this is a uh british influencer who
identifies as
i think non-binary korean
how do you feel about this channel
that's pretty common these days i mean
if they want to do that go for it but
that's what he says he's
like north and
a bts member he's trying to look like a
bts member right now i am korean whether
people accept it or not what was he born
in korea
he's british well that's not the way
this works
we got to stop it at that point yeah i'm
gonna [ __ ] how many surgeries you've had
you weren't born
oh yeah you're not korean papa even
though you
like kimchi you've eaten [ __ ]
yeah
you could love korean culture but yeah
it's it's just interesting how this is a
yeah yeah there you go you can be
non-binary that's who you are but you
are not and you will never be i know
that was just funny uh here's a quick
one this is the cho show you know david
cho
that really a famous artist because he
painted a mural at facebook
and instead of getting a thirty thousand
dollar pay he said i'll just you know do
the stocks
yeah so he gambled and they became like
a two hundred three hundred million
dollars
[ __ ] but he has a show on fx now i'll
play the trailer real quick
i want to challenge myself to like do
the best she was on the show ever done
but also get i'll say yep yeah i can
learn about myself
bobby lee's on it too right
[Music]
how are you feeling i don't mean okay i
mean three
three what are we doing i've interviewed
at least 20 people that was kat von d
are you gonna tell me that you cleaned
up for me i talk to them i get to know
them and then i do a portrait of them i
remember
thinking he's really good on rogan too
yeah the most interesting episodes ever
he's such a cool podcast back in the day
with a dildo in his mouth yeah
huh with the dildo in his mouth yep he
talks about that on rogan that he
recorded one episode with the builders
as well you've created a bunch of
episodes with dill donuts
and rogan's
[Applause]
well that sounds awful yeah because you
used to do it with asa akira yeah
yeah she's great love her work
this is a little older it's like four
days five days old but this guy's like a
celebrity now the sun's in four
yeah so he's like taking pictures of his
face oh yeah
dude he's been doing it he's been doing
like uh he's been doing appearances at
[ __ ]
dude he's famous right now sons and four
sons lost last night now jay thinks uh
the clippers gonna beat him
i don't think so i hope not so i don't
know
suns at six of course clifford's going
to get a game just because they lost one
i mean i know
but broke his nose and
[ __ ] knows yeah hopefully he's not
[ __ ] you don't know you can [ __ ]
shoot with another broken down
[ __ ] a clock [ __ ] everybody [ __ ] y'all
if you doubt me
i don't even want to win the nba
championships if you doubt me
you want some more oh
britney spears came out yeah yeah she
said that uh she was being kind of
fake and it comes out that she was
basically a slave yeah
this is her post i can uh solid
reference chappelle
i know what you're doing i got you
yeah so she just said she was i don't
want people thinking my life is perfect
it's definitely not no we know it's not
we've all
assumed that for quite some time now
what did she come out with yeah what is
she well her dad has all her
rights i think she went in front of a
judge and she spoke for 20 minutes
about the trial just happened basically
what we've all been did you see the
documentary on the britney spears stuff
i'm minimally aware that there is these
you know control issues that she
like when her dad controls everything
from yeah
and not really looking out for her best
interest and it's like she's
mentally capable and they're still
withholding her economy basically
they're forced her to take birth control
she wants to have another baby they
won't ever have a baby
she can't get married again get married
they forced her to
work while she's sick and so they're
saying that she's incompetent of working
now
it's just a big thing wow they make
money
and still like people having these
levers of control over you and the legal
system that is a [ __ ]
nightmare and her dad wasn't in her life
immediately like
right yeah it was her mom oh yeah hey
and then he
yeah i went out for cigarettes and i
just got lost
i got it it was ten years it was wild
anyway
um anyway back heard you gotta
let's not forget okay put your shows in
vegas you're gonna need 90 percent
sign right here and she's making nothing
thank you vegan she's still making me
what else you got jen um this one real
quick
this is dave portnoy on fox business and
then this uh host
let me refresh this real quick he called
him a little [ __ ] little [ __ ]
wow hold up who called him a little bit
i want to see the whole he's a fox
he's a fox anchor damn yeah he was
actually pretty funny
uh-huh oh and he's black so he can get
away with it
oh there's gonna be an ad so let's go
wait because he's probably like you're a
little [ __ ] and white people are like
you a little [ __ ] and this isn't good
yeah
it's just different his deliveries yeah
you know what's devastating is when
chappelle calls people a hoe like he
doesn't say it all the time but it'll be
like it's pretty bad you're a hoe
yeah oh [ __ ] hug this guy who's his
job overcoming a little [ __ ]
no i think they're kind of like homies
here it is
because not everyone sold amc at five
bucks well then
some people helped they wouldn't be
complaining would they
well they might be complaining rich
people complain all the time
because you held and then you go make
fun on twitter of somebody you sold
that's not how it works they're parting
on their yachts would you would you step
up would you stop up for these people
dave
and try to help them out no sense you're
beating me
i'm trying to no i'm not being you're
being a little [ __ ]
listen that's hilarious
gary and say so they have a good rapport
right yeah
what are you getting that's funny though
but just to see that little um
yeah they have a relationship clearly
for the rules to be fixed
this is chappelle's dad if he didn't go
to prison
[Laughter]
that's hilarious yeah is that it dude
delivery with it wasn't
he know what he did you know how to
retaliate dude
you being a little [ __ ] you being a
little [ __ ]
do something that's good that's all that
was like
i know you're right you're right
uh tour date for you guys thick boy just
dropped today the sleeveless hoodie see
chappelle
mark myself we're at zoo is available
today
at thickboy.com the shorts and the
hoodies are available today
thickboy.com thick with three [ __ ]
c's yeah refresh that there you go oh
look at mark right there
i'm him we cute what's up man cutie
please
um where's my face
do we not get a did we not get
chappelle's face
oh you know what it is because the black
background yeah oh my god
no he was sick because kyle what you
were saying no it's not my words i
didn't
you said oh you didn't want to bring it
up okay no yeah
uh so think boy.com for all that we'll
have a new episode of the vlog droppings
every sunday at uh thick boy on youtube
and then dates for you guys we just
added a bunch man but la
finally first spots in la july 16th
through the 17th that's at
haha's shaub and friends july 16th
through 17th
tacoma washington just hit july 29th
through the 31st
vegas nevada august 12th through the
14th
rallied north carolina august 19th to
21st
san jose september 9th through the 11th
then on san antonio pre-sale goes
live next week san antonio a t event
center that's a big
one for your boy tickets at uh
thickboy.com
that's t-h-i-c-ccc boy.com for all
tickets and tickets now
yep really okay yep i know what you're
doing dude all right just making sure no
no
what's your name uh july 15th through
the 17th baltimore maryland with goobies
and then uh finally calling it baltimore
yeah finally i will i refuse to say that
luther real timonium
uh and then in august which i'm really
excited for
bray improv one night i'm gonna be lit
lit lit you know what i'm saying
tickets at f a t k c marcus and i got um
i'm going to costa rica july 5th through
the 19th so if you have any gym
recommendations
if you are
what not my choice you know i'm like a
five-day vacation guy that's yeah yeah
i'm just live
through the night man what do you think
of that yeah
are you moving in costa rica i think
i don't know i might not make it we've
got tour dates if i got a job or
something i'd be like hey i gotta go
yeah yeah commercial issues you know
we'll find out costa rica
yeah lots of sloths and um spiders stuff
we'll get you out now you have fun
for july have you ever taken a trip that
long
we're on the same page here i'm not
really like a two-week vacation guy
all right kiddos love you guys have a
great weekend